six months ago a handful of billionaire
oligarchs in silicon valley
decided to censor and ostracize the duly
elected sitting president of the united
states
now president trump is fighting back by
suing
big tech to reinstate his social media
accounts
i just want to say that i stand before
you
this morning to announce a very
important
and very beautiful i think development
for
our freedom and our freedom of speech
and that goes to all americans
today in conjunction with the america
first
policy institute i'm filing as the lead
class representative a major class
action lawsuit against
the big tech giants including facebook
google and twitter
as well as their ceos mark zuckerberg
sunder buche and jack
dorsey three real nice guys
our case will prove this
censorship is unlawful it's
unconstitutional and it's completely
unamerican we all know that
we all know that very very well
the squishes hate this lawsuit
i love this lawsuit and it's got a lot
more merit than people are giving
president trump credit for while you're
right to question the political process
your right even to point out the
difference between men and women
comes under attack from the big tech
censors all sorts of radical leftist
speech is flourishing
a famous gay chorus is singing about its
plans to convert your kids their word is
not mine
the nation's largest teachers union
doubles down on the right to peddle
critical race theory in schools
and blm attacks the american flag i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knoll
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from jenna janiki
who says joe biden should announce his
preferred pronouns are they
and them since they is our president
this is a good point
when biden is there and he says well
they told me to say
they told me i'm not i i guess they is
his pronoun because they
they is governing us really it's enough
to
give you a real headache enough to give
you a real it's sort of like a hangover
i feel and when i want to get rid of
something like that
i turned to liquid iv i hosted a
bachelor party a couple of weeks ago
you know as one does at the bachelor
party we
indulged in some adult beverages okay
just just a handful or a couple dozen
handfuls or
many adult beverages and we took one
delicious pouch
of oh that wonderful wonderful powder
and we felt much better the next day
liquid iv baby that's what i'm talking
about liquid iv
hydrates faster and more efficiently
than water alone i
do not think i would have survived this
bachelor party
without this great stuff more vitamin c
than an orange as much potassium as a
banana
healthier than sugary sports drinks no
artificial flavors or preservatives and
less sugar than an apple it's also
really good if you're working out and
you know you just want to
you just want to kind of hydrate
yourself but especially if you're a
derelict like my pals
liquid iv great way to hydrate grab your
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code michael at checkout 25
off anything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
michael liquid iv.com trump is suing the
big tech billionaires for censoring him
the question that a lot of people are
asking is is this really
a free speech issue well there are
really two questions here
is it a first amendment issue and is it
a free speech issue because it's not
it's
same broad topic but they're actually
different questions so there are
lawyers who are rather expert in this
field i'm thinking of
alan dershowitz former professor
emeritus at harvard law school
i'm thinking of eugene vollock really
really prominent lawyer and commentator
who say you know maybe this lawsuit
does have some merit on first amendment
grounds maybe it's a big maybe they'll
have to prove it in court
is this a free speech issue absolutely
i think the days of build your own
twitter twit google's a private company
they can do whatever they want build
your own facebook or whatever that's
over first of all they won't let us
build our own twitter
we tried to we've tried to do that
several times and they just won't let us
do it
second of all if
you control the speech
of a democratic republic if you and
let's say two of your buddies
in silicon valley control who are the
guys it's we've got hipster rasputin
you've got jack dorsey
you've got mark zuckerberg and then
you've got in president trump's words
sundar pucci it's
sundar pishai and i love that president
trump did not even take the time to
learn his name he's the head of google
but if you if you and your two buddies
control
the flow of information around the
internet if you control 90 percent of
speech in the
digital realm which is the public square
now you
are by definition engaging in a
political act
because in a democratic republic speech
is politics and politics of speech this
is the theme of my book speechless which
is available now as many of you have
heard
so you are even if you're you don't work
for the government
you don't frankly google and face and
facebook
and probably twitter for that matter
have a cozier relationship with the
government than i think many people are
aware of
but even if they did not even if they
just pretended to be totally private
companies
if you are controlling the speech around
a republic you are engaged in a
political act
and the people have a right to have a
say in that political process
like mitch mcconnell said as
establishmentarian man as mitch
mcconnell
he said a a corporation
can act like a parallel government and
in this case the the
those corporations in silicon valley are
even less accountable to the people
than than the jokesters in in washington
dc
so this absolutely is a free speech
issue this i think is the defining issue
of our time i think it's more important
than immigration
i think it's more important than tax
cuts i think it's more important than
whatever is going on in iran and syria
this is the issue that that will
determine
who rules us and how we are ruled so
thankfully
even beyond this lawsuit the house
republicans are doing something good
on this front they rarely do but they're
actually doing something
that we hope will be productive kevin
mccarthy jim jordan
and morris rogers coming out with a plan
to to rein in
big tech when i sat down with
then attorney general william barr back
when was that about a year ago i guess
bill barr said there are three ways to
attack big
tech you go after their section 230
protections their their legal liability
protections and the communications
decency act
which is a law from the 1990s you go
and it was it was created actually
because the internet was exploding at
that time and it just hasn't really been
updated so
you got to update that you can go after
them on antitrust
obviously we just haven't had companies
like this before we took down standard
oil when it when it became
monopolistic but but we just haven't had
a company that controls speech like this
before okay
and third fraud and this is an aspect
that a lot of people haven't talked
about
though barr did bring it up he said
these companies built their
critical mass on a fraudulent premise
that you could follow the people that
you wanted to follow and you could hear
from the people you wanted to hear from
that you would be able to exchange
information and then with shadow banning
with with all of the capricious
activities at these companies
that went out the window so those three
those are three good ways to go after
them
house republicans begin by going after
section
230 this would limit the liability
protections
for the moderation of speech that is not
not protected by the first amendment
it would preclude big tech from
discriminating against americans based
on their political views namely from
discriminating against
conservatives and it would require
reauthorization of section 230
so that congress can can update the regs
this is really good stuff
and probably should have been baked into
the cake from the beginning uh so
let's hope that goes through mandates
that any big tech content moderation
decisions or censorship
must be listed with specificity on a
publicly available website
one of the issues with these companies
probably the biggest issue is not even
that they have rules don't forget i'm a
fan of standards
i'm a defender of standards i'm a
defender of
cancel culture in principle not the way
it's applied but in principle
of course every culture has standards
and taboos but the
issue with big tech is no one knows what
the rules are
we've been joking about how the new york
times keeps snubbing me from its best
seller list
because the new york times best seller
list is not a best-seller list
it does it does not reflect the books
that are selling best in the country
it's a totally opaque process well who
cares about the new york times list
i do care about the public square i do
care about
facebook and google and twitter who are
controlling our political discourse in
many ways
we need to know what those rules are
this would also this bill would provide
an expedited court process
with direct appeal to the supreme court
that would empower state attorneys
general
to go in after big tech and rain and
rein in their power
and it would require big tech to
implement and maintain a reasonable
user-friendly appeals process these are
all
good changes i should hope that the
democrats would get behind this
very likely they won't because don't
forget it's not
the political battle in this country is
not the republicans versus the democrats
it's the conservatives versus
the squishy republicans the democrats
the bureaucrats
big tech the media hollywood the
universities the
lower education the everything it's
so it's extremely lopsided and the debt
the elected democrats are on the same
side as big tech here
and frankly some of the republicans are
too so it's very
uh dubious i suppose that this will go
through but this we should keep up the
pressure i think this issue
more than any is going to be the issue
that defines the country
moving forward when you want to protect
yourself
i would strongly recommend ring there
are a thousand reasons that protecting
your home
should matter to you for me all thousand
reasons
my cute little newborn baby he's not
newborn anymore i guess he's
approaching six months old and so we
still we got people coming over a lot
you know
i'm not talking about burglars i'm
talking about the delivery man i'm
talking about the guy bringing your food
i'm talking about your in-laws
and you are going to make different
decisions on whether or not to open that
door depending
on who who is at your doorstep you can
know who's at your doorstep you can see
and speak to them
from anywhere whether you're in the home
whether you're at the office whether you
are on vacation somewhere on the other
side of the world
with ring ring lets you keep an eye
on every corner of your house no matter
where you are right from your smartphone
go to ring.com
slash knowles can you wlas it's the
perfect way to start your ring
experience
if you have ring already too then you'll
know this is true it makes
a great gift especially a great
housewarming gift as i've given out
start protecting your home today with
ring alarm go to ring.com knowles to get
your ring alarm security kit today build
the system that's right for you have it
up and running in minutes ring.com
knowles ring.com knowles
so we got good news in terms of reigning
in the power of big tech
we got president trump's lawsuit we got
good news we got the house republicans
bill that hopefully goes through
we've got even more good this is so rare
to get good news
in politics and especially rare on the
big tech side
but the sister website to pornhub is
closing up shop we've talked for a long
time and you you hear it in the mail bag
every week young men
not usually women some women i guess
have but mostly young men
writing into this show who are 18 19
years old who say
porn has has ruined their lives some men
even are older than them they'll say
porn has ruined their lives they got
hooked on it when they were nine or ten
years old
they can't break it it's messed up their
view of the world it's messed up their
view of themselves it's
cultivated bad habits and and yet we're
told
by the can't squishes can't
ban porn you can't regulate porn no it's
a free speech issue isn't it
no the idea that high-speed internet
porn
is a sacred american institution
protected by the first amendment would
cause
james madison and john adams and all the
rest of them to roll over in their
graves
but in recent years people have come to
think this very
silly idea i think the tide is turning
on that
i think that the conservatives of i
don't know say the 80s and 90s
who or even probably the 90s and 2000s
who believe that porn is some as
american as apple pie or something
i think that view is is really being
marginalized and i think
that serious conservatives of an older
generation and especially of the younger
gen z generation
i think they're beginning to realize no
this is bad stuff it's like a drug
there's no protection for obscenity just
get rid of it it's just
poison in the culture well good news is
one of these websites is closing up shop
x tube which i guess is i guess it's
owned by the same company as pornhub or
it's a sister site
they are going to close the the
parent company by the way is called mind
geek and i think part of the reason
they're going to have to
start to batten down some of their
properties is because
they are now getting increasing scrutiny
over sex trafficking
over video of rape on on the platforms
so x-tube it only began in 2008 so i
guess it's relatively not that old
but they will be disabling video and
photo uploads
this week and then by september 5th the
site will be shuttered this is good
stuff
this is good stuff it would be a win for
the american free speech tradition if
all these sites
went away it would and
the the people who are calling for this
among the younger generation it's not
the prudes it's not the skulls the
bible thumpers no it's people who are
aware of how evil this kind of thing is
they're aware what is the good that
comes out of that
what what about pornhub or any of these
other websites
really permits society to flourish
nothing nothing at all get rid of it we
can we can know things folks we can know
that some things are really but we can
have some settled consensus actually
and one of the when we can team up with
the radical feminists
the traditionalists the religious right
the even the public some people who are
concerned with public health i guess
public health is divided on this some
people really want you to look at porn
all the time like the public health
agencies told you during the coronavirus
lockdowns but others realize this
actually does this does bad things to
your brain does bad things to your body
when we can form a coalition like that
and say
get rid of this thing let's do it let's
take that opportunity
speaking of creepy sex stuff though
turning to san francisco
the san francisco gay men's chorus
has a message for all you bible
thumping arch conservative slippery
slope
hysterical alarmists they are in fact
coming for your kids you say we all need
lives you can't respect
but you're just frightened you think
that
we'll corrupt your kids if our agenda
goes unchecked
it's funny just this once you're correct
we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
and you will barely notice it
just like you worried they'll change
their group of friends
you won't approve of where they go
[Music]
[Music]
yes we will reaching one and on
there's really no escaping it cause even
grandma likes rupaul and the world's
getting kinder
genzie's gayer than grindr we're coming
for them
we're coming for your children
i think the creepiest thing about this
video
is how talented these guys are
so it actually kind of sounds you're
kind of bopping along to it you think
wait a second
and you're going and this this video i
believe has since been taken down
because it's elicited a little bit of
negative press as
one might imagine but
the the pushback against the pushback is
oh come on guys
oh you religious nuts they're just
joking they're just come on it's just a
joke it's a tr
it's like well is it i'm
i'm sure that this is in part
tongue-in-cheek you're making fun of the
the fears over the gay agenda or
whatever but
what about this is a joke
we're going to subtly redefine the
standards of the culture
done we're going to expose children to
unusual sex stuff especially through the
internet
true that's that's obviously happening
uh we're going to
encourage them to go out to various
protests for these kind of radical
causes
true that's that that is happening
right so it's as
often as the case in jokes there is
quite a lot of truth here and and then
the question becomes a political
question
for the real political
activist radical wing of the homosexual
rights movement
i think there is a widespread belief
that
you should not be able to view any kind
of wild sex act
with moral of program with with
traditional moral appropriation
whether that be of jewish sexual ethics
muslim sexual ethics protestant sexual
ethics catholic sexual ethics
even the old old-timey pagan sexual
ethics
that no there's actually there is this
new
sexual ideology with that pertains to
the kind of behaviors you can engage in
your gender identity whatever you want
to call it and that is the only one
that's acceptable
and if you don't go along with that you
are on the outskirts
of society you should not be tolerated
this reminds me of
there was a piece in the new york post
some months ago
about from a public school teacher in
brooklyn who said that it is now part of
a
curriculum in a public preschool in
brooklyn
that you can choose your own gender and
no one has the right to tell you
what gender you are that is a very
rigid sexual morality that your kids are
being indoctrinated into
the most arch-traditionalist catholic
school in the world
does not have the kind of rigidity and
and uh make this the kind of radical
claims
that that that public school is in
brooklyn or that the gay men's chorus in
san francisco is doing
a joke but what's what is the joke i
think the joke is probably the truth by
the way also just as a rule
to any other choirs out there to any
other people making musical videos
pride month is over i'm not that doesn't
mean that you can't
express your sexual views or desires or
whatever but enough of the damn
musicals okay we've had it we get one
month a year
you can make the musical videos and they
go all around and
and it they often sound sort of pretty
that's it okay no more
no no i'll see you again next june first
speaking of the craziness that is being
taught to your
children the american federation of
teachers president
randy weingarten
just held a conference the aft
conference and
she insisted she insisted that critical
race theory
is not being taught in schools
critical race theory is
not taught in elementary schools
or middle schools or high schools
it's a method of examination taught
in law school and in college
that helps analyze whether systemic
racism exists and in particular
whether it has an effect on law and
public
policy
but cultural warriors are labeling
any discussion of race
racism or discrimination scrt
to try to make it toxic they are
bullying teachers
and trying to stop us from teaching
students accurate history so what she
just said is not true
very little of what she said is true
like on any
i mean let me rephrase that nothing she
said is true and there are multiple lies
that she told
she says that crt is an analytical
framework to discover
whether or not systemic racism affects
society that's not true
critical race theory assumes presumes
that structural racism pervades society
that is the lens through which it views
society and then it tries to change
society
accordingly it did begin in law school
that's a little kernel of truth there
but it has now spread out throughout not
just the
high schools and the middle schools and
elementary schools but through the
military through the media through
corporate america
if in your school you are taught that
whiteness is a problem that pervades
society and that america is structurally
unjust
because of whiteness your child is being
taught
through the lens of critical race theory
that's just a fact
and no lying teacher union president or
anybody else
can change that fact do not they keep
going back and forth
they defend critical race theory they
deny that critical race theory exists
they defend critical race theory
they deny that critical race theory
exists outside of law schools they
they go back and forth don't let them do
it if your kid is being taught
of the evils of whiteness your kid is
being taught through the lens of
critical race
theory you know ben is going to be
talking about
the shocking allegation and
apparent evidence that tucker carlson
was spied upon by the nsa
i was on tucker's show last night i'll
get into a little bit too but go check
out ben's show today also
fellas really uh really pleased to
announce
speechless number one non-fiction
best seller in the whole country
last week i was really really pleased
by that especially because it was the
week going into the fourth of july
weekend so
really something really american thank
you to everybody who has
uh bought the book we've we've since
then sold an unprecedented number of
books
uh the book is available everywhere
books are sold including amazon
in hardcover and kindle edition and
audiobook edition
so you can go get that i think you may
still be able to order a signed first
edition over at premiere collectibles
though i'm not positive i really really
appreciate everyone
who has read the book who's left a
review let me know what you think of it
uh it's really really terrific and i
love that
the libs who are putting together their
own best quote unquote best seller lists
have to uh even even if they can lie
about which books sold the most copies
uh i i really like that we all know the
numbers we also we all saw the publisher
weekly list and thank you to everyone
who's done that it means
no matter how hard that liberal
establishment tries to
suppress certain messages still getting
out gives me some hope for the country
we'll be right back with a lot more
evil white supremacy is pervading the
country
and it's the white racist supremacist is
that the big problem not so sure
hate crimes are way up in new york city
right now they've risen by
a reported 139 percent in 2021 this is
according to new york city police
department data
and so this means that it's got to be
those racist whites right it's got to be
though it's mega country right those
racist
trump-supporting neo-nazis attacking
black people and others right well the
cops say
that they've investigated 320 reports of
possible bias attacks through june
27th this is up from 134 incidents
during the same period in 2020
offenses against asians are up 400
percent
generally not committed by white people
and now it's at 105 reported cases
compared to 21 last year
anti-jewish assaults are up 69 percent
uh reaching 113 incidents this year from
67
2020 again not typically
committed by white supremacists and then
attacks on black people are up uh the
nypd is reporting 28
attacks on black people this year
compared to last year's 15 so a little
less than
double however there are also
11 hate crimes against white people
which is up from
four people in 2020
also up on muslims hispanics and
everyone else
i want to point out here the increase
in the number of hate crimes just as a
percentage of what was going on last
year
is significantly higher against white
people than against black people i know
that you hear a lot about
how white supremacy is the greatest
threat to the country and even merit
garland the attorney general said it's
the greatest terror threat our nation
faces
the data do not bear that out and that
might be a comforting lie for for
liberals but it's just
not true the data do not bear that this
is just this is just one example we're
looking at
hate crimes in new york city it just
just
is not true i think people are really
concerned about this stuff i think
people
are are really concerned with
crime spiking everywhere i mean i heard
a story
of guy minding his own business on a bus
in chicago caught a stray bullet in the
head and died just
just because bullets were flying in
chicago because they can't tamp down the
crime there because
we've got to defund and abolish the
police because we've got to let more
criminals out of prison
according to the left and according to
the squishes on the right
i think people are really concerned with
the surging crime i think people are
really concerned
with their little four-year-olds being
taught that to hate themselves on the
basis of their race
and on the basis of their sex and
actually that they should become another
sex i think parents are really concerned
about that across races across
demographic groups
and yet i think i know people are
concerned about
censorship by the woke oligarchs because
if you say anything to question for
instance
election integrity measures in the 2020
election if you question
the efficacy of the vaccines if you
question
the threat of covet to various groups
you could be kicked off of social media
no people are concerned about free
speech
and yet and yet what does the gop
believe
we need to focus on what's going to be
the winning message
in 2022 well according to the house gop
conference chair elise stefanik
more tax cuts republicans are going to
focus on
economic growth and focus on how we are
the party of tax cuts
and not tax hikes as you pointed out
president biden has proposed
trillions and trillions of dollars of
new taxes whether it's
increasing the rate of the death tax
through the step up or whether it's
getting rid of our tax sovereignty and
farming it out to europeans which puts
american workers and american companies
at a disadvantage
it's particularly troubling larry
because we're coming out of a pandemic
and we still
have over nine million americans who are
unemployed
we need to focus on job creation not
policies such as higher taxes which will
lead to job losses
and i think the polling is quite
interesting this resonates not just with
republicans but with democrats and
independents as well
i know in my district at this time
particularly as americans are facing
inflation the highest rate since 2008
the last thing they want is higher taxes
that yeah that'll get them that's gonna
rouse people
that's gonna that's gonna razz people
another
tax cut wow i expressed some
concerns about elise stefanik she
replaced
liz cheney as the you know a third in
command among republican leadership in
the house
not a terribly prominent position but
still in leadership house conference
chair
i expressed concerns because she
actually had a much more liberal voting
record than liz cheney did and i thought
liz cheney
certainly should be out of position
because she just
took every opportunity to attack
republicans and to attack trump and his
supporters so i knew she had to be out
i said why are we replacing liz cheney
with a woman who's more more liberal
than she is
and i think this shows the problem
i don't think anybody gives a damn
about some slight tax increase i don't
look i
you know i love low taxes as much as the
next guy
i truly do i hate paying more money in
taxes i want to substantially reduce
taxes
a political movement is about more than
trimming away taxes by the way the tax
code is so complex
it like doesn't even matter that much it
doesn't because there's so many
loopholes there's so many questions
no one has any idea what they actually
owe to the federal government in taxes
don rumsfeld famously sent a letter to
the irs when he when he turned in his
taxes he said
dear irs i just want you to know i have
no idea whether or not my tax returns
are correct
i'm a fairly intelligent guy with a
college degree and i've got very
powerful expensive accountants and none
of us have any idea because the tax code
is so complex
if the right makes arguments
from trimming away at the edges and
making the liberal establishment a
little more efficient and now let's
spend a little bit less and then and
we'll tax a little bit less
they are not offering voters an
alternative to
the liberal establishment they're not
they're just they're they're saying that
they're going to be
more efficient liberals they're going to
be more efficient managers or something
the only issue as far as i can tell that
we've made any progress on whatsoever on
the right in the last 50 years
is abortion because we've at least held
the line and you'll notice
that is maybe the one and guns a little
bit too actually
those are the one or two issues
where we're not making efficiency
argument we're not making utilitarian
arguments we're not making managerial
technocratic egghead spreadsheet
arguments we're making arguments from
justice
this is right this is wrong this is the
way reality is this is why we're not
going to tolerate
the destruction of babies in the womb or
the
curtailment of our clear second
amendment constitutional rights
those are the issues we went on because
people want justice arguments they're
we are not primarily motivated by
keeping a few extra pennies in our
pocket
why the gop can't understand that
is beyond it's not beyond me it's
because the gop
lacks a substantive moral vision it's
because the gop also lacks courage to
stand by its convictions
the few convictions it actually does
have
democrats are talking about a lot more
than just raising taxes okay democrats
are
have an actual ambitious substantive
vision for the country
that includes by the way going door to
door knocking on your door
and trying to get you jabbed with the
experimental drug
that is what am i allowed i don't know
what am i allowed to say
on here anymore am i allowed to point
out that
the vast majority of people in this
country do not face a particularly grave
statistical risk from covet am i allowed
to say that
i hope i am i don't know i get sometimes
i get pushback i'm not allowed to say
these things
it's obviously true the cdc admits it's
true all the data admitted it's true
nevertheless joe biden is going to go
door to door
not personally joe biden can't even walk
outside his own door but joe biden's
thugs are going to go door to door and
try to get you and your kids jabbed with
this thing
it's not just gensake saying this it's
it's
joe biden himself in today's briefing
we discussed how our administration is
going to devote the remainder of the
summer
to a special focus on five ways to make
gains in getting
those of you who are unvaccinated
vaccinated
because here's the deal we are
continuing to wind down the mass
vaccination sites that
did so much in the spring to rapidly
vaccinate those eager to get
their first shot and their second shot
for that matter if they needed a second
now we need to go to community by
community neighborhood by neighborhood
and often door-to-door literally
knocking on doors
to get help to the remaining people
protected from the virus
the virus that's so dangerous that a lot
of people don't want the vaccine the
vaccine which is so great that you've
got to go door-to-door to get people to
take it right that's what you got to do
not a really compelling argument i think
there are there are plenty of people who
are probably on the fence about the
vaccine well i don't really need it but
maybe i'll get it i don't know i'm kind
of
on this age maybe i'll do it when
they hear that government thugs are
going to go door to door
i think that's going to make them less
likely to get it
and at least some democrats by the way
are beginning to realize
huh maybe we're going a little bit too
far
one of the big hobby horses of the
democrats recently
has been voter id they make this
argument that
if you have voter id laws if you have to
prove that you are who you say you are
in order to cast a vote
that this is somehow racist because you
know black people they're completely
unable to get
an id they just how how could you expect
black people to know how to get
an identification card that's that's so
outrage they can't do that
they're not capable of that say the
democrats so james clyburn
democrat congressman majority whip for
the democrats
he is now trying to shift this because
it turns out the majority of americans
support voter id
including according to some surveys the
majority of black people no matter how
much propaganda shove down their throats
so jim clyburn comes out and he says
hey by the way i always supported voter
id
we are always for voter id
we'll never afford this uh
proportionate voter id when you tell me
that you got to have a photo id and a
photo for a student
activity card is not good but for a
hunting license
it is good that's where the rub is
i don't know of a single person who is
against
ideas themselves when they go to vote
but we don't want you
to tell me my id is no good because i
don't own a gun
and i don't go hunting now this sounds
like a stupid argument
but there's actually a sort of
cleverness to it
he's saying no i support id i just don't
think you need to show a picture
no i think what if i you know i i show
up let's say i've got
i've got this piece of paper and then i
draw a little guy with some hair and a
little italian nose
and a smile and says michael here you go
here's my id
here's my id no there's no photo on it
and it's not standardized in any way and
i have no idea if it's an official
document or not but
that's one all we all support that we
all support
ideas that you can very easily fake we
just don't support
ids that are trustworthy that you can
rely upon
and his other argument is well you don't
according to some of these states you'll
need to show a more
official form of id to vote than you
would to buy a gun
right because voting is
a more significant act for our electoral
system
than buying a gun right because buying a
gun
is your constitutional rights right laid
out right there in the second amendment
whereas voting has always been
throughout american history
significantly uh
has always involved significantly more
regulations it's a system
that is established by the states there
are lots of rules that go along with it
and you should have to prove you are who
you say so
james clyburn is admitting that
the the principle is fair enough he's
actually granting the premise to the
conservatives yeah sure you should be
able to to prove who you are
but then in practice he's totally
undercutting he's saying but you
shouldn't have to actually prove who you
are
it's a it's an interesting argument i
wonder if more democrats are going to
pick up on this thing
because it it it's the same kind of
gaslighting
when republicans point out the democrats
trying to pack the supreme court
democrats just redefine the term right
they say no you because you've
you appointed judges to vacancies so
you're packing the court so that's not
what court packing means court packing
means
adding new seats to us to a court well
no but what if it means this other thing
hey yeah no we support voter id
you're the ones who you want
disproportionate voter id what what
you don't support voter id if you don't
actually think you need an official
document with a picture to prove who you
say you are
it's a curious by the way james clyburn
just to
show you how disingenuous this is he has
previously said south carolina's voter
id laws are remnant quote reminiscent of
post-reconstruction jim crow laws
recently called georgia's election
safeguards quote the new jim crow
he called i voter id laws in 2020 form
of voter suppression so it's completely
disingenuous he's just
i think he's looking at the polling and
saying oh
this isn't going to really play very
well in in peoria
and speaking of id speaking of
proving you are who you say you are and
people knowing who you are
you know tucker carlson made this claim
on his show
a week or two ago he said the nsa is is
spying on me
they have obtained my emails and they
are going to leak them in an attempt to
take down this show
and the left made fun of him and said it
wasn't true and the squish republicans
said no this isn't true
spoiler alert the nsa is not spying on
tucker carlson then the nsa came out
and issued a fake denial and the left
and the squishes all said oh
see this is proof that the nsa didn't do
that and i said remember i read it on
the show
i said read the words of this
quote-unquote denial they didn't deny
anything
they didn't they just very cleverly
arranged their words
to give the impression that they were
denying spying on tucker but they never
actually did it which by the way is in
itself
very good evidence that the nsa was
spying on tucker
well tucker has got the receipts he's
got the actual proof now
tucker carlson comes with proof last
night
to his show that the nsa was in fact
spying on him take a listen they don't
actually have anything on me but they do
have my emails so
i knew they were spying on me and again
to be totally blunt with you
as a defensive move i thought i'd better
say this out loud because i have no i
have no other way to defend myself i'm
just an american citizen i don't have
you know any position of official
authority but i do have a megaphone so i
should say this out loud and i did
and the nsa didn't deny it then
yesterday i learned that and this is
going to come out soon that the nsa
leaked the contents of my email to
journalists in an effort to discredit me
i know because i got a call from one of
them saying oh this is what your email
was about so
it is not in any way a figment of my
imagination it's confirmed it's
true they're not allowed to spy on
american citizens they
are i think more ominously they're using
the information they gather
to put leverage and to threaten
opposition journalists people who
criticize the biden administration
so he makes this point tucker actually
first teased this on maria bartoroma's
show on fox business
coincidentally i happened to be on
tucker carlson's show last night we were
talking about
big tech we were talking about the the
manipulation of speech in america and
this this is the flip side to that
which is the nsa goes in they're
spying on all of us but usually we are
masked you
at least that's in theory usually in
theory they can't tell
whose information is whose then in the
case of tucker carlson gets unmasked and
the proof is
axios gets a scoop tucker carlson sought
putin
interview at time of spying claim
tucker carlson was talking to us-based
kremlin intermediaries
about setting up an interview with
vladimir putin shortly before the fox
news host
accused the national security agency of
spying on him
sources familiar with the conversations
tell
axios sources who are the sources
the source the kremlin i don't think so
i think the source
is the same people who were spying on
tucker carlson there's no question about
it
the squishes in the left won't admit
that they were wrong they don't care
because they're shilling for the
liberal establishment of which the nsa
no such agency
is is apart
the reality of our government is really
jarring to some people because we are
taught
in civic well now we don't have civics
classes but when we did have civics
classes you're taught that
the government works with the three
branches of government the checks and
balances and the separation of powers
and i am a bill up on capitol hill and
i'm
you know no that's not how it really
works
the the nsa doesn't fit into that scheme
does it
it's not really taught about the nsa
you're not talking about mass
surveillance on americans
in the fourth and fifth grade you're
taught about creepy sex and how boys are
actually girls but you're
you're not taught about about all the
rest of that stuff this is pretty
jarring
and now that i since i went on tucker's
show last night just does that mean
they're spying on me now
yeah i hope not don't send me any weird
emails guys that that would be a really
really bad idea seems like we need to
rein that in not just the private
companies on on
the big tech side we have to do that too
but also also the government
john mcafee another tech pioneer
just uh got got suicided in a jail in
spain
remember he allegedly killed himself
even though he had said for weeks i'm
not in
months and months he said i'm not going
to kill myself people are trying to kill
me if i turn up suicide and don't
believe them
people are trying to murder me and then
he shows up suicided so
john mcafee's wife says the story of
john suicide was already prepared
and presented to the public before i or
his attorneys were even
notified of his death words cannot
describe how enraged i am at the fact
that i had to hear the news of john's
death via a
direct message on twitter so she wasn't
even told now it's being conveniently
reported there was a suicide note found
in his pocket something that was not
mentioned when i collected john's
belongings from the prison and another
piece of information the media somehow
got a hold of before myself and john's
attorneys
the investigation into john's death is
still ongoing but i will share what
information i can when i can until then
i do not accept
the suicide story that's been spread by
the malignant cancer that is the
mainstream media they and their unnamed
sources are not to be trusted
of course that's true of course of
course they're not to be trusted
just shows you i mean the fact that none
of us really believes that john mcafee
killed himself the fact that none of us
believes that jeff ramstein killed
himself
that is some crazy stuff when you when
it reveals to you how
political power actually works
in our country and throughout the west
speaking of potentially being hunted
down by agents of the state
spike lee filmmaker particularly
of the black power variety uh spike lee
wearing a 1619 hat
just lamented at a recent conference
black people are being hunted down by
the police since you brought up do the
right thing
a couple weeks ago was the 32nd
anniversary of the film that film came
out
in 1989 i wrote it
in 1988
when you see
brother eric garner
when you see king george floyd
murdered lynched
i think of radio rahim
and you would think in hope that
30 some [ __ ] years later the
black people
stopped being hunted down like the
animals
black people are not hunted down like
animals none of the data show that
whatsoever it's not
not even close the idea that black
people are being hunted down by police
is an absolute farce
it just doesn't happen the idea that
george floyd is a king
is also suspect it's just we're just
living in this
bizarre narrative that is so
disconnected from reality spike lee
might genuinely believe these things
he's wrong he's hallucinating he's
imagining these things
but that that is the power of speech in
a republic you know
blm blm of utah didn't know there was a
blm of utah
utah not the blackest state in america
but okay there's a blm of utah
just came out and said that the american
flag is a symbol
of hatred you know
you know i hate to say i told you so but
i said this this is this is the power of
speech and the power of standards we now
have a new
national it's the black national anthem
we now have a new international
independence day it's called juneteenth
it's
right there in the title of the bill we
now have a new
origin story of our country it's not
1776 or 1620 it's 16 19. we now have a
new sense of ourselves it's not a good
country it's an evil country it's a
racist country
we're gonna have a new flag we already
do sort of have a new flag
because the star-spangled banner is a
symbol of hatred this is th this
is the power of speech we've got to get
a handle on speech and on our narrative
or else we're gonna have a completely
different country if we don't already
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show new allegations emerged
that tucker carlson was caught up in a
surveillance sweep and his emails leaked
by the deep state that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen